good afternoon everyone
all of you here
in this beautiful concert hall or
wherever you are in the world watching
this live stream
I'm Abrahim I'm the founder and
president of the accessing shoot and
it's a great privilege to welcome all of
you on behalf of the Nexus Institute to
the next lecture of President Emmanuel
macron
allow me to extend a very special
welcome to the presidential delegation
from Paris
excellence
destinations
um
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen dear friends
as we are living in a time in which so
many important words are misused or have
lost their meaning I would prefer to
avoid big words
yet it would be false modesty not too
observed that in all objectivity today
all of us are attending a real
historical event
75 years ago in 1948
our continent had become synonymous with
two world wars 100 million deaths the
poison of nationalism racism
totalitarianism Holocaust Outreach
and because of that darkest period in
our history in the year of 1948
many political leaders and intellectuals
such as Churchill I don't know foreign
came together here in The Hague
with the Congress of Europe to sow the
seeds of what will become our European
Union
sure that what happened in the first
half of the 20th century would never
happen again
in a sovereign United and Democratic
European Union there would be no place
anymore for the politics of Lies
resentment hatred nationalism and
extremism
but now 75 years after that Congress of
Europe
our continent is again affected by many
crises including a never-expected war
and given this background it is
historical that here in The Hague at the
Nexus Institute once again A World
trailer the president of France Emmanuel
macron will use this stage to present
his vision on the future of Europe
now before I turn the floor to the
president in in a minute
let me explain briefly what you can see
here on stage next to the usual Flags
also the flag of the Nexus Institute
and this connection to my invitation to
president macron to deliver a Nexus
lecture
in 2006
our Nexus lecturer was piano Starker who
was one of the most famous sellers
players in the world in 20th century
he was Hungarian Jew safai from the Holy
Ghost
not his two brothers
they were killed by the Nazis
after the war
against went to the U.S where he
together with a few friends founded the
school for classical music in
Bloomington Indiana
and the idea behind this school is to
keep alive in education that Hitler
wanted to destroy
an education in building
in a profound knowledge of the Arts and
education in The Pursuit Of Truth and
beauty
unfortunately the school is still there
and it is still one of the best
now I saw Janos for a last time 10 years
ago not long before he died on April 28
2013.
and when I was about to leave he
suddenly said to me
Rob carry the flag
and the fact he was referring to
flag of the oldest Republic in the
history of humankind
the flatiano Starker kept in mind is the
flag of the Republic of laers
the Republic's ideas
the Republic of a Cosmopolitan spiritual
Heritage that offers people the
opportunity to cultivate around Saul
can we deflect John block my old friend
with whom I founded in 1991 the journal
Nexus founded in 1962 a Bookshop and a
Publishing House
in which he published the most beautiful
editions of the classics and poetry
with the same intention as Jana Starker
to keep a culture now a book culture
alive that the Nazis wanted to destroy
as without a world of books people would
get lost in their own ignorance
can we deflect that's what George Stein
a dear friends of both young black and
the Nexus Institute did with all his
work
being alive the tradition of a bag of
Spinoza the tradition of a European
humanism with its idea that our lives
are a quest for meaning and this liberal
education is an education in the only
nobility that counts the nobility of
spirit
carry the flag our flag symbolizes the
Nexus Institute intends to be part of
that Republic of ideas the Republic of
European humanism
and this for this reason that I have
chosen 30 years ago this quote for
Margaret yuseness beautiful novel
meanwhile Adrian as a motto I quote
men fortunate enough
to benefit to strong degree from this
Legacy of culture
seem to be responsible for protecting it
and holding it in trust for the human
race
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
on April 24th it is exactly one year ago
that a few thousand supporters of
President macron assembled us the song
Demarcus at the foot of the Eiffel Tower
nervously waiting for the results of the
presidential elections
Evelyn and I were among them
exactly at 8 pm
the news we were all hoping for popped
up on the big screen with almost 60
percent of the votes Emmanuel macron had
won the elections
and around one and a half hour later I
was already getting dark
arrived if his wife Brigitte family and
friends
and when they walked to the stage the
music of Beethoven you just hear it was
played the cellos introducing the theme
of The Fourth Movement of the Ninth
Symphony of Beethoven
and certainly I understood by all her
supporters were given
at the entrance of the chandi Mars this
flag
the flag of Europe
Emmanuel macron
wanted us to know that he would be a
president who in his heart he says
francaise as a citizen of the Republic
of ideas
that he wants to be a political leader
who carries the flag
not only of France but also the flag of
the idea of Europe
thank you
so join me
in a warm welcome to a monologue
[Applause]